okay
we've been talking about tommy who
started xyz
which was which was uh integral in our
early careers
and tommy says that back in the day when
you're
uh part of the xyz skate supply thing
he says dude back then derdick was a
daryl they're just
drunk and smoking weed and [ __ ] and uh
yeah and then it wasn't until uh
he you went to this uh dr pratt
dr pratt who was a a hypnotist i would
probably put it
in you know i got so much success
early right turned pro quickly you know
got everything we're moved to cali dc
happened all this stuff
and but i also just partied
so much right like not not like
you know you know deep heavy uh stevo
level days
right but like you know i was
i was burning away the career but what i
ultimately burned away with that
was like self-belief right like i
i really then ended up like questioning
myself and like could i even still be
pro and
and do i even have what is my life going
to be like
what if i'm not a pro skateboarder
anymore right which was
hammered by ken block saying
uh you know when i was 24 that like we
think your best years are behind you
and we're gonna give you one more uh uh
two-year contract
uh before you retire right so it was
just like i just
partied my way into [ __ ] being
retired
and i went to george pratt
on this idea of he wrote this book hyper
success
and he was a hypnotist and this is back
in the phone book days
i was just looking through the [ __ ]
phone book because there was no [ __ ]
internet of like oh clinical
psychologist like hypnotist right i'm
like oh this is at la jolla scripps this
is legit
and and he the first test he did on me
was like you don't believe you were
meant your subconscious doesn't believe
you are meant to be successful
and then lo and behold we did a handful
of sessions and and i never
i've never taken a step backwards never
again in my life right and maybe i was
ready maybe i
that was my moment in time like and i
was ready to like find and regroup
but i had since you know took all my
friends there i take my wife there
i just celebrated my fifth year uh
wedding anniversary and did a full
wedding and he or he
he did the ceremony yeah i mean like
that's
you know all these years later i still
look at him as this
sort of you know at least integral piece
of just
you know being this this this conduit
that took me to this entirely other
level
epic man do you keep going back to
refresh with him like
or you're still rocking off that initial
you know i don't all all like you know i
i said um
you know i saw him not that long ago i
just want to um like verify that my
subconscious believes i'm going to be a
billionaire
and he's like you know does some like
magic's like stop
you already know that anyway
but you know for me i also have done so
much
deep work on my subconscious
and basically clearing out so much
aspect
that i live in this like super super
sharp
presence with like super clear long-term
goals so i end up in sort of this like
this state where i don't really question
much
and sort of attract all of the things
that i need to perpetuate me towards
those long-term goals
so it worked where'd you get the sense
enough to look for a hypnotist
like when ken block told you you know
you're going to retire like what made
you
go through the phone book and be like i
think a hypnotist is what i need right
now
i don't that's a really [ __ ] very valid
and straightforward normal question
right like what the [ __ ] why and then
when you say it to me i'm like well god
damn it what was the strategy
i know i'm [ __ ] up i need someone to
hypnotize me to not [ __ ] up
you said some daryl [ __ ]
i went through i went to him the test to
stop biting my nails and it worked for a
week and then i haven't been able to
stop biting my nails the last 20 years
so i don't know what the answer is
two different stories two different
stories
so going back to then you know you you
see you see
dr pratt and uh then
like your your what year was it you saw
dr pratt you think
well [ __ ] if i was 25 so that was 20
21 years ago right so or maybe 24 so 22
years ago
so you know like late 90s right 97 98
took a huge you know i had
hip-hop labels and you know skate i had
i was doing all types of businesses and
all types of stuff and
it also i refocused on my state career
only
and then like you know i told ken block
in that meeting i said look
in two years i will be a completely
different
person and at the end of that two years
i was like top ten in the world in every
single contest
like i grinded the 20 stair handrail for
the mtv commercial like i had just like
literally it rededicated my life to
skateboarding and then like
completely like re-engineered re
re completely invigorated my career then
i would
only sign two-year deals right and i
said because every two years i'm gonna
be even bigger and better and that led
to then robin big
then only a two-year deal and then
fantasy factory only a two-year deal
like i
i did all of that until i finally signed
a 10-year deal
and then they went out of business yeah
yeah dude